all right I have been wanting to talk to
you for so long well I mean at least it
you know since the first season came out
I just I think um let me see if I can
figure out how to say this I think that
you see those people and they have that
thing people call it it or that sort of
you know
um energy uh and you just do you're so
alluring I I it's so wonderful I'm so
happy for you I'm gonna cry whoa it's
true though thank you I mean I I was you
know it's like okay so you auditioned
for this role is it true you had to
audition in your friend's closet at one
point yeah I was actually here in New
York and my friend didn't have a big
space and so he didn't have a wall that
I could actually audition on and so was
it on Zoom it was on Zoom okay this
makes much more sense right it was on
Zoom yes yes and uh Morgan Cooper he
called me and he said we want to do one
more creative session with you and I was
like what is a creative session it's a
nice way to put it right yeah and so and
so I got in a closet and I I got on the
call and Will Smith actually surprised
me and told me I got the role while I
was in my friend's closet
the news himself he did yeah I
sprawl in a
big thing to come out on and I'm so
happy for you and like you and your cast
mates
um I hear you're like a musical group
what what are you doing musically
but we do love this series there's a
group that like yeah you sing like a
Ensemble you know and so I I love
playing piano I started with music but
uh and so I love playing piano on set
and we love singing together what what
like what song did you last sing well
coming here I sung a song called Drew
Barrymore
[Laughter]
I love it it's so good I'm so honored
that like my name is in the most
beautiful song of hers okay so that's a
good one to sing yeah um okay I in the
introduction mentioned a sweeping
Obsession that you have it's true
what how I look like a stain removal
Obsession so this kind of is adjacent
yeah why should we say something about
it like I'm not gonna stop until the
floor is absolutely spotless you know
what I mean like it's just something I
think maybe it's like a form of OCD or
something I don't I'm not sure but and
that's okay like that you know I I might
have that a little too with the stain
removal like I I would I would oh I
happen to know yeah you guys have a bro
okay I thank you John so much John
appreciate it
is there any sweeping technique that you
can show me on a carpet my mom would be
proud of me because like if you grew up
like I did sometimes the vacuum doesn't
work right and so like you just like you
like to sweep really hard to get
everything out kind of and that's the
you know really this this is the side
that does all the work for me you know
you can get into really small corners
and or under counters under beds and you
find some interesting stuff I was gonna
say I heard a story where you were
sweeping under your couch and found some
interesting items yeah yeah I I I I
threw a party I used to throw parties in
Philadelphia and uh afterwards I was
cleaning up my house and I was sweeping
and I found a condom
and it wasn't mine it wasn't mine but
interesting interesting stuff was it the
condom or the rapper the rapper excuse
me sorry yeah I don't know is this when
you look at like this um utensil or
vessel are you like I do like this but I
would prefer a different type of person
I do prefer a push broom well because I
used to do like a Swiffer no like a like
a standard yeah like the flat wide one
yeah
let's do it bun like you know yeah yeah
because I used to do theater and so I
used to come in before the show and
actually sweep the stage myself just to
calm myself yeah just to calm yourself
may we all find that thing that makes us
happy and by the way
the aftermath is cleanliness which they
say is Next to Godliness exactly you got
it will you stick around for the rest of
the show with us I would love to really
I would love to
recipe and then we've got a curling
thing which is sort of like sweeping
stuff exactly let's hang okay perfect
we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]